[Music]
this
me
welcome to this virtual memorial for
louis conf
my name is arthur mcewen i was a friend
of louise
that doesn't say very much to identify
me because
louis had very many friends those of you
who are attending this event and many
more
it of course tells us something about
louis that he had so many friends
his multitude of friends were very
important to him
but perhaps i can identify myself a
little more by saying that as a
professor of economics at the university
of massachusetts in boston for many
years
i like to think of myself as one of
louie's go-to guys
for economic issues
in this memorial you will hear from
several
of louie's long-term friends friends
from different parts of his life
i will introduce them as we go along
also we will have some music a
interlude among the presentations from
fran schubert and at the end
another coal train is body and soul
also after the presentations
gene jackson louie's partner for over 30
years
we'll have a few words to say regarding
gene
i want to recognize all the work she did
in bringing together this memorial
event it's plenty of work to put
together
a memorial during normal times
to put together a virtual memorial
however
is a lot more work let me tell you
that so many thanks to gene for bringing
us
this event i met louie
through our shared political activity
one of the things
that always stood out to me about him
was his commitment to left-wing politics
i learned a lot about this commitment
by reading the interviews that we have
posted
on the memories website memories.com
and i would urge you to read it too when
you have a chance
you will as i did probably learn uh a
great deal more about louie than you
already know
in order to get us started i
want to read a bit from those in one of
those interviews
louie in the interviews was asked the
question
what were the beginnings of your com
political commitment
in washington heights louis responded
he said if i had to choose
a particular incident it would be
something that happened to me
when i was about 14 years old my mother
sent me to the delicatessen to get
something
the deli contestant was on broadway
between 162nd and 163rd
i walked in and there was a black man
there
of course the word was colored that
particular time
and he had bought something and he told
the clerk that he had been shortchanged
a nickel
the clerk insisted no such thing had
happened and the black man said
look i need that nickel it's important
to me
i'm poor whereupon the guy said
okay you can have your nickel
at that moment at that moment two cops
came storming in with brass knuckles on
their hands
and they just beat this guy into a
living pulp
i mean there was blood all over the
floor
then dragged him out bounced him up and
down on the floor as they were dragging
him
and his face had disappeared it simply
wasn't there anymore
and i stood there wondering
isn't somebody going to say something
about this isn't somebody going to say
stop stop this is bad
well nobody did and i couldn't believe
it
i went home and i told my parents and
they simply shrugged their shoulders
i guess maybe they assumed i made it up
since things like this don't happen in
america they only happen
on the other side and at that
moment at that at that point
i started to ask some questions about
what the situation of blacks
was in the united states i started
reading the newspapers
the pm which carried a lot of articles
by if stone and i started
educating myself politically
commitment to progressive politics to
left-wing politics
was an important part of louie's life
but it was only a part by no means the
only important part
the friends you will hear from today
will provide a more complete picture
the first of these the first among these
friends
is marjory bakken marjorie is the
president emeritus of wheelock college
for 25 years she along with her husband
harold
and their daughter martha lived with
louie and others in the house at 1214
glenwood avenue
in cambridge louis and marjorie shared a
deep friendship
for 50 years she will read louie's
letter to his friends
written shortly before he died marjorie
thanks arthur and now i'm going to read
the letter
made 2020 to my dear friends
you know who you are my abject apologies
for the disorderly mess i left for you
to take care of
rarely haven't been known for my tact
further apologies for any feelings i
might have heard
during our intense dives into the
dialectic
i have tried to live a personally and
politically
decent life not always with success
the positive things i've accomplished
came about
through the wise guidance of my friends
as well as the challenges posed by my
students
the follies and dishonesties emerged
from my neurotic needs
i've been so lucky to be the recipient
of the spiritual strengths
you dear friends bestowed on me
enough lest we drown in a swamp of
sentimentality
be good to yourself have fun
kick ass given my current circumstances
my only hesitation i feel about dying
is leaving you wonderful people louie
louis lived in a house on glenwood
avenue for 50 years
called the faculty house by the
neighbors the house came to have a
mystique of its own
and it became the symbol of the durable
and affectionate
ties among the people who live there
louis was the central most significant
person for us
in the house and for the neighbors
lots of conversations in the house were
domestic
ordinary talk i'm going to start
cleaning the basement on saturday
who can help me do that jim driscoll is
coming tomorrow to fix
outlets on the first floor anybody home
turns out that louie and um jim became
very fast friends
i need a ride to the airport harvard
square mit
at 3 p.m is anybody available
there was no email no texting no cell
phones
we all schlepped up and down the stairs
to communicate
to share our lives there was fun
and joy elaborate birthday celebrations
particularly for phyllis ellen and
harold
who had december birthdays days apart
in those celebrations louis was the chef
i was a helper
fest of homecomings for people who had
been away
celebrations for completion of a
dissertation
a book an article visits from parents
family members friends
their agreed upon tasks caretaking of
two babies
soon little girls shoveling snow
hauling garbage care of the swimming
pool
including when it sprang a giant leak
and flooded the neighborhood
there were political activities
neighborhood sister city projects
marches through the local stop and shop
to protest the vietnam war
as well as participation in local and
national protests
there was sadness the death of a parent
a separation a divorce people leaving
the house
louie was always the energetic keeper of
the friendships
cherishing us and our children in ways
that allowed us to cherish each
other i have had for many months
a sticker on my kindle given to me my
mag by maggie my granddaughter
it has become my daily message from
louie
wake up kick ass be kind
repeat to live on
in the memory of others means that you
do not die
thank you thank you very much marjorie
our next presenter is paul water
paul is the allen k
and gwendolyn miles smith professor of
literature emeritus
at trinity college he and louis
in 1972 published the politics of
literature
paul has just published a new book
our 60s which he says is essentially
about his life as an activist and
educator
in the 1960s and 1970s paul
i'm one of those who can say
louis was my dear friend uh it's one
measure of him that there are as author
said literally
dozens of us who might say the same
thing
some years ago when i had been operated
on for lung cancer
louis called me every day literally
every day
for more than a month to make sure that
i was okay
he was likewise there for many others
in sickness and in health
being there entailed a good deal more
than hello how are you
he always engaged what was or should
have been on your mind and certainly his
israel-palestine the exploitation of
adjuncts and what the mla or
radical teacher could or could not do
about it
what anyway did we mean by publishing a
magazine on
on radical teaching for most of his
91 years he was engaged with
these and the other political worries
about which
he was occasionally known to fret
we work closely together even at a
distance since i was always
in and around baltimore or washington or
new york or someplace and he was always
up in
cambridge and we even performed that
ultimately
uh intimate ritual writing together
in fact however we often deeply
disagreed
and about nothing so much
as his decision to pack it in
it was a conclusion which troubled me in
ways that has been hard to fathom
and about which i thought every day when
we talked as we did
when he was in the hospital at hospice
and as i described walking about with my
catheter but i could never bring myself
to question his decision
it was after all his to make
or was it i'm pretty sure
we could have argued a talmudic length
over that question
i might have said you
have socialized your life
but now you privatize your death
but i didn't i was intimidated
and so i came to silence
re rescued from that silence in the
echoing halls
of poetry in this case by edna saint
vincent malays
dirge without music which i will
now read
i am not resigned to the shutting away
of loving hearts
in the hard ground so it is
and so it will be for so it has been
time out of mind into the darkness
they go the wise
and the lovely crowned with lilies
and with laurel they go but i am not
resigned
lovers and thinkers into the earth with
you
be one with the dull the indiscriminate
dust
a fragment of what you felt of what you
knew a formula a phrase
remains but the best is lost
the answers quick and keen
the honest look the laughter the love
they are gone they are gone to feed the
roses
elegant and curled is the blossom
fragrant is the blossom i know
but i do not approve more precious
was the light in your eyes than all the
roses in the world
down down down into the darkness of the
grave
gently they go the beautiful
the tender the kind
quietly they go the intelligent
the witty the brave i know
but i do not approve and i am not
resigned
thank you
thank you paul both
for your words and for your reading
the next speaker is martha the cenas
martha vecinis taught for many years at
the university of michigan
where she was the eliza m mosher
distinguished
university professor of english
women's studies and history
she first met louis at the infamous 1968
modern language association meeting
martha says she learned from louie and i
quote
to look critically at our profession and
to read beyond the anglo-american
literary tradition
and i quote again most of all louis
encouraged me to challenge
and love my students and myself martha
all of us know that louis was a
brilliant friend
both intellectually and emotionally
however great his intellectual prowess
he poured himself into being the kind of
friend he wanted us to be
and i think we tried hard to meet his
expectations
we all experienced his gentle criticism
and his absolute loyalty i am grateful
that before he died i was able to tell
louis
that he has always been my best and most
faithful friend
over 50 years he was unfailingly kind
supportive and honest when i needed it
and i have two very disparate anecdotes
here
one is how many times he read the
manuscripts
that we sent him how many times he then
asked for a copy of our book and then
read the book
and yet always offering criticism
that was somehow so palatable
so acute yet at my most difficult point
he immediately came to ann arbor knowing
that listening can be healing for me
as for many of us he is irreplaceable
today we meet as a small number of the
many friends who love
and remember louie's impact on our lives
many of us are at the age where we've
lost dear
friends people we've relied on for
decades
are now gone louis lived a long and
fulfilling life
and yet i'm still learning how to
reconcile myself
to life without him
we have come together to celebrate
louie's life
and to share our grief for we must now
live without his comforting presence
i am very happy that i decided to retire
here because i had 12 years of being
in his neighborhood and many many
lunches in harvard square
with him these and
i think these memories are really what
helps us
in this period of grief i have chosen
elizabeth bishop's poem one art which
suggests
that the loss of someone we love is
simply
and painfully part of the many losses
that plague us daily yet in the end
bishop makes an ironic turn
and writes that after all there is only
the irreplaceable loss of someone we
have loved
louis the displaced austrian jew who
battled so hard to make his
native country better sorry his adopted
country better
always understood that irony was the
best defense
against laws
one art by elizabeth bishop
the art of losing isn't hard to master
so many things seem filled with the
intent to be lost
that their loss is no disaster
lose something every day accept the
fluster of lost door keys
the hour badly spent the art of losing
isn't hard to master then practice
losing farther
losing faster places and names
and where it was you meant to travel
none of these
will bring disaster i lost my mother's
watch
and look my last or next to last
of three loved houses
the art of losing isn't hard to master
i lost two cities lovely ones
and vaster some realms i own two rivers
a continent i miss them but it wasn't a
disaster
even losing you the joking voice
a gesture of i shan't have lied
it's evident the art of losing isn't too
hard to master
though it may look like write it
like disaster
thank you very much martha our next
presentation
is by dick ohman
dick ohman is the benjamin weight
professor of the english language
emeritus
at wesleyan university he and louie
met when louis arrived at harvard in
1958 and they spent three years together
as junior fellows and many more years
together on various activities including
the radical teacher
dick louie and i talked from time to
time about death
his feelings and intentions were clearer
than mine
a few years ago i asked him if he had an
idea how he would die
suicide he said without hesitation
i was surprised but now understand what
he meant
setting standards for the quality of
life he would accept and choosing the
time
and manner of his leaving it i admire
that though the loss hurts
he said to me several times he hoped he
would die before i did
i know he said the same thing to others
as an expression of gratitude
and friendship i believe
how did he expect us to get on without
him
i bet he expected me to write a poem
i thought of emily dickinson's because i
could not stop for death he kindly
stopped for me
with louis it was just the opposite
here he is the costing death and the
voice
of emily dickinson
because death would not stop for me i
spoke to him please give
not glory or eternity but
simply not to live with bodily
decrepitude
short breath and failing heart
nor in brain-addled geezerhood where
sense and syntax
part mr death i'll ride with
you drive past the setting sun
take me on where i can view coldly
oblivion thank you
thanks dick thank you very much the
pictures you will see on the screen
are photos that jean jackson took on
cape cod
where she and louie vacationed every
[Music]
summer
the next presentation is by phyllis ewen
phyllis ewen is an artist and i should
note
louie had three of her her pieces three
of her pieces
hanging in his apartment she was a long
time friend
and cambridge neighbor of louis phyllis
and her husband jim campin enjoyed
spending loving times
with louie and gene over many years and
now continue this relationship
with gene phyllis
thank you arthur i met louie when i was
in 1967 so we were friends from most of
my
life as with all good friends he was
just there just here
so i keep expecting to run into him as i
walk
or hear his voice when i pick up the
phone
i miss as other people have talked about
his loving concern
his ambitious smile his occasionally
caustic wit
and his keen intelligence but mostly i
just miss his everyday presence in my
life
as many of you know when in conversation
he might insert a quote from literature
a reference to history politics or a
song
or comment on a sports figure
but every once in a while louis
surprised me with a reference
to a poem that illuminated illuminated
something i've been thinking about
i read a lot but poetry is not my habit
but louis did read poetry and he knew it
intimately here's one occasion
between 1995 and 2005.
i fabricated installations out of indoor
outdoor carpet
the inexpensive version of astroturf
used
in the city in working-class
neighborhoods to simulate lawns
these outrageous plants and hinges i
placed into the natural environ
environment as a comment false ferns
quaking bog lawn chairs were some of the
individual pieces
louis gave me the title for the entire
series
green thoughts this came from a line and
a poem by 17th century poet andrew
marvel
not a grief poem but a life poem
the garden because the poem introduced
me to another side of louis
i will read some of the stanzas
the garden by andrew marvel fair
quiet i have found thee here and
innocence my sister dear
mistaken long i saw you then in busy
company of men
your sacred plants if here below
only among the plants will grow society
is all but
rude to this delicious solitude
no white nor red was ever seen
so amorous as this lovely green
fond lovers cruel as their flame cut
in these trees their mistress's name
little alas they know or heed how far
these beauties
hers exceed fair trees
where air your barks i wound
no name shall but your own be found
what wondrous life in this i lead
ripe apples drop about my head the
luscious clusters of the vine upon my
mouth do crush their wine
the nectarine and curious peach into my
hands themselves do reach
stumbling on melons as i pass and snared
with flowers
i fall on grass meanwhile the mind
from pleasureless withdraws into its
happiness
the mind that ocean where each kind does
straight to its own resemblance find yet
it creates transcending these far
other worlds and other seas
annihilating all that's made to a green
thought
in a green shade here at the fountain's
sliding foot
or at some fruit trees mossy root
casting the body's vest aside my soul
into the bowser's glide there like a
bird it sits
and sings then wets and combs its silver
wings
until prepared for longer flight waves
its plumes
the various light
the poet argues for a life of quiet
contemplation against
living actively in society
so it seems that louis camp urbanite
and activists also
needed and loved some quiet solitude
where his thoughts could grow and expand
a green thought in a green shade
thank you louie
thank you very much phyllis the next
speaker the next presentation
is saul slappakov saul is retired from
tufts university
where he taught both biology and
american studies
he and louis developed their friendship
in the anti-war
and draft resistance movement of the
late 1960s and early 1970s
they were close friends ever since and
close neighbors
in recent decades saul
louie was above all a great friend
we met in that in 1967
with the coming
louie was a great above all a great
friend
we met in 1967 with me coming out of a
10-year hiatus
in political activity
at that time we met before i we met
because i was invited
to attend the board meeting of resist
nationwide organization committed
to resisting the draft
resist was anxious to recruit people
like me
and hill to hide to become knowledgeable
and to work with boston area draft
resistance groups
louie was the person on the board who
oversaw
hilda hines in my work with the draft
resistance movement
louie and i got to know each other
in this political context
it was also the hope of the resist board
that hilda and i
would work
and keep the local deaf draft resistance
groups
off the back of the national office
which was housed in central square
cambridge
it was also the home of the resist board
that held an
ike
okay sorry about that
my friendship with louie was
strengthened by a daily morning phone
call
during these things among others we
talked about
articles in the boston globe new york
times
when i read the globe he read both and
would inform informing of issues
not covered in both papers we would
compare how each paper
focused on a major topic like the
israeli occupation
of palestine for example or we exchanged
our responses
about human interest stories
louie always began reading the newspaper
by reading the obituary and sports
sections
in the newspapers and then
in the obituary columns you would look
to how people have lived their lives
what could he learn from others lives
experiences reading sports reflected his
engagement with sports
first as a player at long island
university
on their basketball team which was a
leading basketball
power and then later he taught sport
at mit where he taught a course
on sports in america for him
sport both distracted people from major
life problems and
also reflected major political
and cultural events in the contemporary
world
for years our morning cause began very
early
in the morning soon after six
because each of us was living alone and
we were early risers
later when i began my relationship with
flora
and he was gene we spoke closer to aid
when flora was up and having breakfast
often louie would end up having a short
conversation with flora
particularly to informer of latin
american
cultural events reported in the new york
times
for much of his lifetime louie was
passionate about the arts
from grand opera to early music to jazz
and country
everything in between louie also
developed art museums
dance theater and film
during the 1980s there were many more
jazz venues
than there are currently in the boston
area
we go to hear jazz three or four nights
a week
we befriended the pianist james williams
and on occasion went out to lunch with
him
louie often engaged musicians in
conversation
between sets for after
on a less serious question louie was
quite sensitive to his own
self-presentation
while in hot summer weather louis would
proudly support
watson t-shirt with an explicit
political message
he often wore the radical teacher
t-shirt for example
as soon as the weather got a bit cooler
and want a movie self presentation
change markedly he might wear slacks in
the sport jacket
and occasionally even a certain time
oh he was fortunate having a friend
george siegel
whose family manufactured menswear
and who supplied louie with clothes
produced in his family's
businesses in wintertime where he
favored corduroys with his wheat jacket
and leather elbow patches
at his 50th birthday party allen and his
first wife bought louie some ball
deeply colored shirts when we saw them
he inadvertently
planched and expressed that as ever
wearing them
because they were too bold my
recollection is a little lazy
but i think louie actually
wore them on a few occasions
in his long relationship with gene who
we benefited from gene
keeping an eye on for sales and
encouraging louis to be a little less
conservative in his choice of clothes
ultimately he dressed like a consummate
college professor
i miss louie i'll keep him close to my
heart
always thank you very much saul
our next presentation is by ruth perry
ruth perry is the anne federer
friedlander professor of humanities
at mit she was the first woman at mit
in to be tenured in the literature
department
from within the ranks rather than being
brought in with tenure from outside
she started the women's studies program
at mit
in 1984 and louis started teaching
in that program a few years later she
was a colleague of louise
for many years and organized a
symposium in his honor when he retired
in 1996 ruth
thank you
i first met louis when i came to
interview at mit
in 1971 the department into which i came
was very different from what it turned
into
and only recently have i realized that
the marvelous cohort of 18
junior faculty members was a legacy
from louie's chairmanship of that
department
they were a radically committed and
deeply intellectual group
jack mcneese lillian robinson alan
berger peter herman
susan gerard and many others at the very
first meeting
i attended someone pointed out that
since
i was the person in the room with the
youngest child
i ought to have the first choice of
teaching times
i seriously thought i had died and gone
to heaven
this was feminism in action
most of those radical junior faculty
members were against the war in vietnam
they met regularly with others from the
humanities department at mit
to plan and run anti-war demonstrations
one old friend remembering those days
told me about louie's remark one
afternoon when a few of them were
folding flyers
for an anti-war event seeing a cigar in
my friend's shirt pocket
louie told an anecdote about big bill
hayward
the early labor leader released from
jail in chicago
after the 1919 assault on lay on unions
at the press conference following
hayward's release
a reporter tried to provoke him by
asking
how he could justify smoking a cuban
cigar
that cost a dollar but big bill took a
puff and said
gentlemen nothing's too good for the
working class
in time all those vibrant young people
left
or were not renewed by the by then
conventional leadership of the
department because they were not going
to write their theses or publish enough
in the right places
or otherwise fit the successful academic
profile
only two of us out of that original
group were left standing in the end
and certainly during my own trials and
tribulations i always felt louis
supported me
he wrote a short story for the radical
teacher
about the departmental meeting on my
tenure case
with barely disguised descriptions of
the senior faculty
and their fatuous remarks
in the story he represents himself as a
resigned
onlooker rather than an active fighter
louis had been a student of the
enlightenment which was my field as well
and very soon after i was hired he
invited me
to peruse the bookshelves in his office
and take any of the 18th century books
that interested me
i very happily made off with an eight
volume set
of lucky's history of england to which i
have had recourse ever
since although he never disparaged me
for continuing to work in the field
he once explained to me that he was not
going to work on poets
that would never have given him the time
of day because of his class and being
jewish
alexander pope would never have
tolerated him at dinner
and he felt that the authors of the
period were ideologically complicit
in the kind of imperialism and
jingoistic nationalism he detested
in 1968 louis was one of 130
mit faculty members who signed an open
letter to mit's president
howard johnson urging him to end mit's
relationship with the department of
defense
noam chomsky also signed that letter and
the two of them
taught a joint seminar for the next four
years on the subject of american
imperialism
and that seminar had a huge enrollment
mit had its share of demonstrations in
marches sit-ins classroom disruptions
everyone trying to put pressure on the
institution to renounce the funding of
the defense department
mit was at that time one of the top 10
universities
receiving funding for military related
research
and not until 1973 following a heated
faculty meeting
did mit affect a financial separation
from lincoln laboratories
which was where such research continued
but early in 1969 some students abetted
by some faculty
used a battering ram to break into the
office of president johnson
and occupy it for 34 hours after which
negotiations failed
and the administration called in the
police
louis did not incite or conspire with
the students but he certainly supported
them
joining the sit-in and supplying them
with food
johnson was unforgiving louis lost his
chairmanship and they froze his salary
in the records of the university there
are letters
from wayne o'neill who followed louie as
chair of literature
accusing the administration of
discriminating against louis
on political grounds and a memo
in those files about keeping a professor
who was being courted by brandeis
because he was a
stabilizing and moderating force to
balance
louie's leftist leanings
he talked new york but he wrote with a
european handwriting
and he had an unusual mixture of
laid-back insouciance
with the knowingness of the konoshenti
in our literature meetings he didn't say
much
but tended to come in whenever there was
an impasse
to say something sardonic or cynical
which sometimes broke that log jam of
hardening positions
he taught subjects in american
literature and culture
contemporary literature and world
literature
and he could quote most sources in its
original language
the topics of louie's subjects like the
famous sequence he taught
called american voices ranged widely
instead of traditional categories like
fiction drama or poetry
he organized it around categories like
ballads from gerta to willie nelson or
songs by working class women
louis was the first male professor in
the fledgling women's studies program in
in 1984 and for a while the only male
professor his support for the program
was very important
and the sports course um that saul
mentioned
was taught in our women's studies
program
he taught subjects in women's literature
and in practical feminism
in which the students went into the
community
and wrote up their experiences they
worked in such
organizations as rosie's place a women's
shelter
or the our bodies ourselves storefront
health information clinic
our mit students tended to be extremely
useful to these
organizations and would overhaul their
computer systems
and give other kinds of technical
support
indeed it was an immensely valuable
subject and we've been talking lately
about reviving it both to honor louie
and to do some good in the world
thank you thank you very much ruth
our next presentation is a joint
presentation
by irene genzer and assaf
fourie irene like louie
was from a european refugee family and
she grew up
in the same washington heights but irene
was about 10 years behind louis and it
was later
in cambridge that that as
she notes and i quote louis became part
of the landscape of my life irene is now
retired from boston university's
political science department
assaf who is a professor in bu's
computer science department
has been both louis friend and louis
consultant
on things related to mathematics
and theoretical computer science who
knew
louie was interested in theoretical
computer science
irene and this off
uh louis was i think of him as
being permanently present in my life
although in fact we met many many years
ago
i did not know him in washington heights
but
we did talk about that common past
common
european refugees not with any
particular nostalgia but simply
recognition of that
the way it was but louis was a witness
in my in the transformations of my life
and was unconditionally loyal
curious always asking about what i was
working on
even though it was far removed or so i
thought from his own interests
uh this continued until very very
recently and
his interest also extended to our family
assaf will talk about that i'm thinking
now about
our son alex and grandchildren and so on
so
for me louis is as they say
presenting thank you
thank you all for saying that i was
louis consultant in mathematics and
computer science
well the fact is at one point well first
of all
whenever something related to
mathematics and computer science
came up he would call irene i don't like
to talk on the phone i have some kind of
fog about that
and he would say i want to talk to
herself and then he would say
something like maybe an orbit about a
mathematician
or some result in mathematics and he
would ask my opinion on it
and i was always impressed because
whenever it has to do with
culture music jazz american writers of
course i would turn to him
and he had something to say
and something that this is my own little
secret i even have a paper in
mathematics believe it or not
that once i was explaining what it was
and he said i would like to read it
are you sure louis you'll be able to
read that just give it to me
and i gave him a paper uh
mathematics he read the introduction he
read
the first part the conclusion and came
back with
comments telling me this is not very
clear this is clear you can do it better
and so on
well okay so here we have a sense
it's not only the politics that put us
together
but also a a way of interacting whatever
the person is okay so
and coming and and really trying to help
out
one thing that i would like something
that came to mind before
i was going to see more on that but when
i
uh i saw that art planned to put the
schubert the office 100 on in the middle
i thought one day that's many years ago
uh i'd like to show off too that you
know okay on anything related to the
culture louis be there and
he'll have a lot to say to me so i
thought maybe i would
try to to impress him
that morning that many years ago i heard
on the radio the schulbert 100
office 100 and afternoon i happened to
have also
a the same city at home
so uh the next weekend when we saw him i
told her we look i have here a cd i'd
like you to hear
it is by the bose trio
what is that is the bose trio b-o-s-e
trio and i'll put it on
and then what do you think and then he
said this is the bozar trio
i thought probably he would be fooled
the way i was fooled myself in the
morning when i was listening this to the
radio
the announcer on wcrb start by saying
now we're going to put
a trio by schubert the 100 office 100
is by the bose trio and i was totally
puzzled
i listened it was very beautiful and at
the end
he kept repeating this is the bose trio
and finally before turning off he said
that was the bose arch trio
then i thought probably before the same
way well
he wasn't fooled by it immediately he
recognized was the bizarre trio
anyway thank you
thank you very much assaf and green
also let me thank all
of the presenters it's been very
moving and very interesting and i
appreciated
what everyone had to say
i would like now to turn things over
gene jackson
to say a few final words gene
well first of all thanks so much to all
of you
watching this memorial event
uh we very much appreciate the offer
appreciated the opportunity to put this
on
thanks also to the presenters all of us
are dear friends of louis we
miss him terribly we think that he would
have enjoyed this
a great deal although he did not like
compliments so some of it
he he would have been embarrassed by um
and uh finally i want to thank don
morton
and her team at mit video productions
without your help we could not have done
this
thank you very much
hmm
hey
[Music]
and
him
do
[Music]
to
do
[Music]
you